dans cette affaire la justice a besoin
de plus de temps du temps pour éclaircir
certains points notamment établir le
parcours précis du chauffard le soir des
faits ce 21 décembre 2014
le prévenu se livrent à un véritable
rodéo dans les rues du centre ville de
dijon
en quelques minutes il renverse et
blessent 13 personnes il est très vite
arrêté et mis en examen pour tentative
d'assassinât
mais à l'issue de l'instruction aucun
document reprenant le parcours du
prévenu n'est versée au dossier
ces premiers éléments que le juge
d'instruction à nouveau saisi devra
établir dans le cadre de ce complément
d'information
le second point concerne les victimes
car il semblerait que plusieurs
personnes parmi les treize blessés n'est
pas été cités jusqu'à lors un point a
corrigé donc un point essentiel dans le
cadre notamment des procédures
d'indemnisation de ses victimes
alors une fois ce travail effectué et le
dossier devrait être réexaminée par la
cour d'appel de dijon le 29 septembre
prochain
une affaire qui sera vraisemblablement
suivi de près car je vous rappelle
qu'elle avait fait la une des médias
nationaux il ya deux ans
le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve avait d'ailleurs fait le
déplacement à dijon fin 2014 contre
prévenu il est actuellement incarcéré à
la maison d'arrêt de dijon voyez
derrière moi il est pris en charge par
le service médico psychologique et son
sort pareil d'ailleurs déjà scellé il
devrait être reconnue pénalement
irresponsable à ce moment là il ne sera
pas jugé mais plutôt placé en
internement d'office